hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
the trailer for 1917 which if it has a
year like that it's most likely a war
moving that's what I've learned from
Hollywood's history before we hop into
this I wanted to give a special thank
you to today's video sponsor you might
have heard of them before Ridge wallet
let's show them some goodies that John
relied on to survive Comic Con this year
absolutely right in fact I mean we got
to start off with the ridge wallet nifty
minimalist metal-plated fits nifty in a
front pocket shirt pocket wherever you
want it they also make these awesome
weatherproof backpacks built-in charging
port power banks man they got a whole
bunch of really useful stuff and I
really love using it go check out some
rich stuff today Ridge comm slash reject
nation use the code reject nation to
save 10% and it's free shipping so Wow
don't oversell it I really enjoy this
this thing man you can charge like your
phone five times you can turn to lap I
said you're overcooking I'm sorry
ice love the ridge
that's a trailer for the trailer Dunkirk
is a good movie I really enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
you have a brother in the second
Battalion yes sir
is he alive and with your help I'd like
to keep it that way but they're walking
into a trap
the orders are to deliver a message
calling off tomorrow morning's attack if
you don't we will lose 1600 men your
brother among the wire
Oh
boss of that standing
if you fail
boy of course now they're neither leaf
blowing right outs you know they should
give us a schedule you know I should put
in writing when and where there couldn't
be doing it it's just so random it never
falls on the same day of the week that's
one big complex you know you think it
would be on a schedule like every tenant
is where you gotta film around it once
in a while right outside man it's real
though that's what the people pay to see
when they come here to the for YouTube
well this looks great
I'm hoping this is R rated PG no you
know what I mean Dunkirk was pg-13 at
first people were a little bit raising
eyebrows because how can you pull this
movie off and make it pg-13 and it
worked up first this one specifically
since it's a lot more on the ground with
what they're dealing with and even had
that one eerie moment where he's like
the soldiers are probably on top of dead
bodies and it's Sam Mendes too and it
was like the last couple of Bond movies
or pg-13 he's made some really good
r-rated flicks and I feel like an a war
movie this time period specifically
World War one just being a liberal on
the ground floor and also to really help
distinguish it from Dunkirk even for an
r-rated would would really work to its
benefit I mean I would I would honestly
be very astonished if it wasn't r-rated
because yeah it's like how do you tell a
war story that isn't you know dunkers
about rescue but this seems like it's
about at least braving battle to prevent
a you know an attack or a battle that's
gonna go wrong this just looks so
harrowing the yeah if they pulled that
punch I would honestly be upset even
just based off this little trailer
because I thought this was a really
really effective trailer I just love the
aura and the mood and the really tense
gripping tone they struck from like yeah
very beginning like it's deliberate and
yet really intense looking I don't know
how much crap I'm gonna get for
consistently compared to Dunkirk but the
trailer seems really mapped out to sort
of reflect
like the Dunkirk style at least you know
like the ticking clock sound and the
clock was the thing that reminded me the
most of course the whole aesthetic of it
all it's a different I mean this is not
World War two World War one you know at
least it like the mood of it all
however there are things I really did
stand out to me Roger Deakins is
cinematography I think it looks
absolutely excellent as always the best
cinematographer working today and he's
shot most of Sam Mendes's movies if not
all I'm not sure if he hasn't if he
skipped one or not but for sure he shot
most of Sam man as his films got this
composer Thomas Newman who's doing his
own Hans Zimmer riff that Newman family
runs deep but she got his distinctive by
yourself by being somebody your own
family I mean they've worked together a
hell of a lot and yeah I think this plot
sort of reminds me of Dunkirk meets
Saving Private Ryan actually I wonder if
that brother thing is made up to make it
feel more personal curious we didn't
save 1600 people your brother is one of
them so now it's a personal mission you
know ya don't know how I made up that is
I'm not sure if this is like an untold
true story or if this is something
that's just made up during World War one
like though there's barely any
information released on Wikipedia just
had this one little plot description
here that I found in between a jump cut
that says two British soldiers
experienced one harrowing day while
fighting in World War one
yeah they've kept the details really
under wraps about this I mean I guess I
would be surprised if this wasn't based
on something real just because you know
I feel like a lot of war movies
especially now want to at least route
themselves in a real event or something
and this sounds like the kind of thing
that would be a true story because you
know the point I think of a lot of these
types of war movies is to show the
triumph of the human spirit and inspire
and you know show the lengths these guys
are willing to go to to you know carry
out the order and save these people I
guess I would feel kind of funny if it
was a just a fully made-up story
I'm sure jostling something real is just
the brother thing that's where it makes
it feel a little bit like Saving Private
Ryan to me yeah yeah like there's one
Ryan left III you gotta go save his ass
and I think this is produced by Hamlin
entertainment which is Bill Driscoll
yeah so that would make some sense
having an infused in here and even
though I didn't like Sam Mendes his last
Bond film Spectre loved this trailer
because they intentionally said director
Skyfall I really love most of his films
road to perdition iconic that's a semi
hail as one of my favorite movies of all
time and this does look like one of
those things about throwing you
literally into the trenches of this
specific day this time the mood of it
all like you said or yeah and and I feel
like there's gonna be a lot of these
tracking shots it feels a little bit
alfonso cuarón sort of type a direction
a little bit of like children and men
infused feels like a lot of these like
these very long tracking shots that you
have in this trailer I feel like there's
a certain yeah like desire Birdman
yeah with these kinds of movies it makes
a lot of sense you kind of want to
showcase just how far we went to
recreate this situation and it really
immerse you into what these people would
have been dealing with I feel like that
is one of those war movie things where
you always want people to feel as much
of the experience as you can just the
look of this those tracking shots
combined with the kind of light they're
using and stuff just made it look really
unsettling and uncomfortable and and it
really looked like yeah like a gripping
harrowing warm the World War 1 aesthetic
- I appreciate that we're doing that
more now because it's you know less
explored in cinema that we're always
read about there would it be a world war
2 with that one guys but you know like
the the type of fighting you're doing
the weapons and stuff you know
everything is different and there's a
different kind of soldier spirit I think
that goes with that I mean you know
they're all soldiers are soldiers this
comes out on Christmas Day that is
exactly where I want to be I say [ __ ]
Star Wars yeah we're watching 1979 new
double feature a long long time ago and
then a longer time yeah and then cats
and then Kansas capital and feel good
Colin Firth and mark stronger and this
this is the real prequel to Kingsman
that [ __ ] you saw earlier
yes month
and then benedict cumberbatch is gonna
join you know the king's man this is the
perfect setup all right guys are you
excited for 1917 leave a comment below I
hope you are and you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification Bell big thanks to rich
wallet again for sponsoring this video
it's just so and last but not least I
would like to give a shout out to a man
named low hit banerjee mm-hm
low hit is a guy who every month is one
of our top of our patrons and he always
requests these awesome cinematic game
trailers and we've had a lot of great
conversations back and forth he's a film
enthusiast he has some new roommates
were all creative types living together
yet this entire month he's ignoring me
he hasn't gotten back to me once to let
me know what awesome game trailers we
should check out for the month of July
looking at this 1917 trailer this is his
kind of style like this is it was game
animated this would be exactly the kind
of video he'd send to us so I wanted to
show you about to let you know I haven't
forgotten about you even though you've
forgotten about me just like how all of
you have forgotten that World War one
started it burst before there was World
War two give respect to origins are
right road warrior wouldn't exist
without Mad Max Dark Knight wouldn't
exist without Batman Begins really pay
respect to the really pay respect to
started on yeah we're getting there
first this is too far it's too late too
late for these jokes I mainly offended